what is the hierarchical cluster
analysis a hierarchical cluster analysis
is a clustering method that creates a
hierarchical tree of objects to be
clustered the tree represents the
relationships between the objects and
shows how objects are clustered at
different levels we asked people how
many hours a week they spend on social
media platforms and in the gym the first
thing we do is plot the people on a
scatter plot with this we can now start
to create the Clusters the first step is
to assign a cluster to each individual
point so we have as many classes as we
have people the goal now is gradually
merge more and more clusters until
finally all points are in one cluster in
each step the Clusters that are closest
together are always merged